we have observed in the simple example
from the previous clip that when the
Markov chain initially starts in state 1
the priority that it finds itself in
state 1 after a long period of time
converges to a constant value in our
case 2 over 7 in addition if the Markov
chain initially starts in state 2 the
probability that it finds itself in
state 1 after a long period of time also
converges to the same constant value 2
over 7 are these two properties of
long-term care insurance and of
vanishing effect of the initial state
over the long term convergence always
true mathematically we are asking the
question is our I J
when n goes to infinity the answer is
that for nice Markov chains this will be
true but this is not always true
consider the first question does RI GN
always converge to something and n goes
to infinity look at the following simple
Markov chain when in state two you will
never be in state two at the next
transition you will end up next in
either state one or state three however
no matter where you end up you assure
that the next transition will bring you
back to state two either here or from
here in other words for an odd hour to
two of n will always be 0 and for n even
Archie 2 of n will always be 1 and so
Archie 2 of n will never converge it
will always alternate between 1 or 0
convergence has failed that chain as a
periodic structure and we will see in
the next lecture that if periodicity is
absent from a chain then we don't have a
problem with convergence consider now
the second question dealing with
vanishing importance of initial States
when convergence occurs for this
consider the following Markov chain
if you start in state 1 there is no way
you can escape you are certain to stay
there forever so our 1 1 of n will
always be 1 on the other hand if you
start in state 3 there is no way you
will ever reach state 1 so our 3 1 of n
will be 0 the initial state of where you
started does matter in this example and
its influence never vanishes in the long
run the second nice property has failed
here and here this has to do with the
mark of structure where some states are
not accessible from some other state and
we will address this in the final
portion of this lecture finally let us
calculate R 2 1 of n for large n so you
start in state 2 and you ask yourself
what is the probability that I will end
up in state 1 after end steps for n
large well when you start into you may
stay in 2 for a while by doing this kind
of transition and transition and this
transition but eventually with
probability 1 you will escape either you
will go to state 1 or you will escape to
state 3 and in that case you will never
go back to 2 if you are in 1 you will
never go back here in 2 and from 3 you
will never go back to 2 because of the
symmetry between these probabilities
here zero point 3 on this side and zero
point 3 on this side
when you do escape state - you are
equally likely to escape toward one or
toward three so what you have is that
our to one of n will be one over two